my pilot project for a women's health
research at Yale was about how sex
differences play in together with
tobacco use and also with depression
people who smoke tobacco have a much
higher incidence of depression than
people who are non-smokers and that
relationship between smoking and
depression is one that has puzzled us
and one that we're concerned contributes
to the ongoing smoking and the inability
to quit that's different between men and
women women have a harder time quitting
smoking and also have a much higher
about double the incidence of depression
as men so our project was to look at the
role of nicotine and depression-like
behavior and a basic science model and
also to determine what the sex
differences were in those interactions
and to identify whether this was a
genetic difference or something that was
environmental
what we found is that there is an
interaction between the genes that are
important for for depression-like
behavior that are influenced by tobacco
the nicotine and tobacco and we also
found that the sex differences
interacted with those genes the most
important finding that we had in our
pilot project was that there were sex
differences in these behaviors and
people hadn't been looking at that and
and the interaction between those sex
differences and in particular the genes
that are related to depression like
behavior and the genes that are
important for tobacco use had really not
been established so that we really only
began to look at that with the pilot
project
one of the things that the initial pilot
money from women's health research at
Yale did for our research is to allow us
to have time to develop our model fully
and to get this basic science model of
depression-like behavior established in
our laboratory and validated and that
was a fundamental part of being able to
expand our research and look into these
interactions with nicotinic like
medications and for the interaction
between gender sex and and depression in
further studies
we've been able to find that drugs that
affect the receptors for nicotine in the
brain so those are the receptors that
are stimulated by the nicotine and
tobacco smoke also affect circuits in
the brain that are important for mood
and we've now been able to show that
agents that change the function of those
nicotine receptors could also be used as
novel antidepressant medications we know
that there are a large proportion may be
up to 50% of people with major
depressive disorder who are not helped
by current medications and that means
that there's a lot of room and a lot of
need for new ways to think about
depression and one of the things that
the work that we're doing has
contributed is a new brain system the
nicotinic system in the brain that
normally uses acetylcholine which is a
neurotransmitter we all use helps us
think clearly it helps us pay attention
but it's also a system that we know now
we can change and use nicotine like
medicines to affect depression
the practical value of the research that
we've done on the nicotine system and
depression is that there are currently
medications that have been developed
that target these nicotine receptors
that are in large clinical trials for
depression we don't know yet whether
they're going to be effective we don't
know if in the long term they're going
to become good antidepressants but at
least we have the hope that these
clinical trials will lead to a new way
to treat depression that will help
people in particular who are resistant
to current medications and these
nicotine like medications are being
added on top of that to see if we can
now help people who were resistant to
treatment
you